>> Tucker: FOR DECADES
JOE BIDEN FREELY ADMITTED THE
ROE V. WADE DECISION WAS BAD LAW
AND INHERENTLY EXTREME.
I DON'T LIKE THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION, I DON'T THINK A WOMAN
AS A SOLE RIGHT TO SAY WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN TO HER BODY WHICH
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
CREATE A BABY WITHOUT A MAN, WHY
IS IT NOT A MAN'S ISSUE TOO,
SHUT UP, THEY SCREAMED!
JOE BIDEN HAS CHANGED HIS VIEW,
NOW HE WILL SAY PRECISELY WHAT
THEY TELL HIM TO SAY.
TODAY HE ATTACKED THE
OVERTURNING OF ROE V. WADE.
>> WE HAVE THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD OUR INFLATION RATES
ARE LOWER THAN OTHER NATIONS IN
THE WORLD.
THE ONE THING THAT HAS BEEN
DESTABILIZING IS THE OUTRAGEOUS
BEHAVIOR OF THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
OVERRULING NOT ONLY ROE V. WADE
BUT ESSENTIALLY CHALLENGING THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
WE HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF PERSONAL
RIGHTS AND PRIVACY RIGHTS AND IT
IS A MISTAKE IN MY VIEW FOR THE
SUPREME COURT TO DO WHAT IT DID.
>> Tucker: WHERE A LEADER IN
THE WORLD IN TERMS OF PERSONAL
RIGHTS AND LESS YOU CRITICIZE
JOE BIDEN ON THE INTERNET IN
WHICH CASE THE FBI MIGHT WIND UP
AT YOUR HOUSE BUT FREE SPEECH IS
NO LONGER A PERSONAL RIGHT.
HERE IN BRAZIL IT IS STILL A
MOSTLY PRO-LIFE COUNTRY, STILL
MOSTLY A CHRISTIAN COUNTRY BUT
THE LEFT HERE WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO CHANGE THAT.
WE SPOKE TO BOLSONARO ABOUT
THIS.
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT HIS GUN
POLICIES AND HOW PROVABLY
ALLOWING THE CIVILIANS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES HAS REDUCED
VIOLENT CRIME, HERE IT IS.
WHAT ARE YOUR OPPONENTS VIEWS OF
CHRISTIANITY?
>> THE LEFT WING, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE ATHEISTS.
THEY DO NOT RESPECT ANYTHING.
THEY CRITICIZE PRIESTS AND
PASTORS AND LULA HIMSELF HAS
SAID HE WILL IF ELECTED TO PLACE
PRIESTS AND PASTORS IN THE
MILITARY IN THEIR RIGHTFUL PLACE
OR IN THE RIGHT PLACE IN
SOCIETY.
FOR INSTANCE WHEN THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT RECENTLY CHANGED
ITS UNDERSTAND A GOOD RULING ON
ABORTION, THE LEFT WING IN
BRAZIL DID NOT LIKE THAT.
WE DID LIKE THE NEW STANCE TAKEN
BY THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE WE DEFEND LIFE FROM ITS
VERY CONCEPTION BUT NOT SO AMONG
LEFT-WING PEOPLE.
LULA IN THE LEFT-WING OFTEN SAY
ABORTION IS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND IT IS THE WOMAN THAT
YOU DECIDE TO.
WE BELIEVE THE LIFE THAT HAS
BEEN GIVEN TO A WOMAN DOES NOT
BELONG TO THE WOMAN AND THAT IS
A STANCE ESPOUSED BY OUR
RELIGION.
THE FEDERAL SUPREME COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE WHO FAVORS
ABORTION HE HIMSELF STATED IS
NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO DISCUSS
THAT ISSUE YET.
AND CASEY GOES BACK TO POWER
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO CAMORRA
POSITIONS TO BE APPOINTED TO THE
SUPREME COURT, HE WILL CERTAINLY
IF ELECTED, HE WILL APPOINT A
CHIEF JUSTICES THAT WILL SUPPORT
THE ABORTION POLICY.
IN COLUMBIA FOR EXAMPLE,
ABORTION HAS BEEN CONFIRMED BY
THE SUPREME COURT.
IN BRAZIL, THE SUPREME COURT HAS
INTERFERED A GREAT DEAL, NOT
ONLY IN THE LEGISLATIVE BUT ALSO
IN THE JUDICIARY OF COURSE.
LULA AND THE LEFT-WING BELIEF
ONCE THEY COME BACK TO POWER, IT
WILL BE IRRELEVANT TO COUNT ON
THOSE WHO ARE ELECTED TO
CONGRESS.
BECAUSE THEY WILL ACTUALLY WIELD
POWER OVER PARLIAMENT.
AND THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
LEGISLATE THROUGH THE
SUPREME COURT JUST AS THEY HAVE
LEGISLATED THROUGH THE ISSUES OF
HOMOPHOBIA AND NEPOTISM WHICH IS
THE POLICY OF EMPLOYING MEMBERS
OF YOUR OWN FAMILY, A PUBLICLY
APPOINTED MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
WE LOWERED THE TAX ON
INDUSTRIALIZED GOODS AND THE
SUPREME COURT SAID THAT WAS NOT
CORRECT, THEY CHANGED IT.
VERY OFTEN THE SUPREME COURT IN
BRAZIL MAKE DECISIONS THAT
SHOULD OTHERWISE ONLY BE DECIDED
BY EXECUTIVES, SUCH AS FEDERAL
TAXES.
>> Tucker: THE LEFT IN BRAZIL,
LULA SEEMED TO BE TRYING TO
INTRODUCE IDENTITY POLITICS,
AMERICAN STYLE RACE, RESENTMENT
BASED POLITICS INTO BRAZIL.
DO YOU NOTICE THIS AND IS IT
WORKING?
>> IT IS A WAY TO DIVIDE AND
CONQUER.
EVEN BEFORE LULA TOOK OFFICE IN
2,003 THE LEFT-WING WOULD
ALREADY PREACH THAT, THE
DIVISION OF PEOPLE ALONG
IDENTITY LINES, BLACKS AND
WHITES, EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES,
PEOPLE FROM NORTHEASTERN BRAZIL,
SOUTHERN BRAZIL, THEY HAVE
GAINED FOLLOWERS AS A RESULT OF
THAT APPROACH AND THE MAJOR
DIVISION AREA SPLIT IS BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
LOTS OF FOLLOWERS AND THEY SAY
THAT, YOU'RE NOT DOING WELL
TODAY BECAUSE OF YOUR EMPLOYER.
THAT DIVIDE OF APPROACH, THE
WORKERS HAVE PROBABLY ALWAYS
GAINED AT LEAST ONE FOURTH OF
THE BRAZIL POPULATION, THEY HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTED BY AT
LEAST ONE FOURTH OF THE
BRAZILIAN POPULATION.
MY FATHER-IN-LAW IS KNOWN AS
BLACK MAN AND I AM BLUE-EYED
WHITE MAN.
RACISM IS THERE IN BRAZIL BUT
NOT AS IT IS OFTEN DESCRIBED.
MOST OF OUR MAIN FOOTBALL
PLAYERS ARE PEOPLE OF AFRICAN
DESCENT, NO WORRIES.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE
LIBERALIZED GUN LAWS, YOU'VE
MADE IT EASY FOR CIVILIANS TO
OWN FIREARMS, WHY DID YOU DO
THAT?
>> I WAS UNABLE TO ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE BRAZILIAN LAW BUT BY
MEANS OF A PRESIDENTIAL DECREE
AND ALSO MINISTERIAL ORDERS,
REINTERPRETED THE EXISTING
LEGISLATION AS BEST AS POSSIBLE.
THERE HAS BEEN A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LEGALLY OWNED FIREARMS
IN BRAZIL.
THE CONSEQUENCE AS YOU SEE IN
THE BRAZILIAN MEDIA IS A DROP IN
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
KILLED BY FIREARMS IN BRAZIL.
WE BELIEVE WE UNDERSTAND ONCE
PEOPLE GET ARMED, THE CROOKS,
THE THIEVES WILL THINK TWICE
BEFORE THEY BREAK INTO OTHER
PEOPLE'S PROPERTY.
IF THE NUMBER HAD GONE UP, I
WOULD BE BLAMED FOR JUST THE
OPPOSITE IS GOING ON TODAY.
IF REELECTED, IF EVERYTHING GOES
WELL, WE WILL HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
SUPPORT IN CONGRESS AND WE WILL
BE ABLE TO PAS